-Guys, it's time to take a look
at the stories making headlines
today with good with the bad.
It's time for "Pros and Cons."
There you go.
-♪ Pros and cons
and pros and cons ♪
♪ And pros ♪
-Tonight, we'll be taking
a look at the pros and cons
of returning from the Olympics.
The winter Olympics just wrapped
up in Beijing,
and all the athletes
are headed home.
So, let's take a look at the
pros and cons
of returning home
from the Olympics.
Here we go.
First one, pro.
Everyone in your hometown will
want to talk to you.
Con, everyone in your hometown
will want to talk to you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Pro, telling your neighbor
you're a curling gold medalist.
Con, getting a text
the next day asking you
to sweep their driveway.
[ Applause ]
-Come on.
-I'm used to it.
-No respect.
-Pro, you just finished the most
grueling feat of athleticism
in the world.
Con, speed eating a Cinnabon
over a trash can
in the Beijing airport.
[ Laughter and applause ]
We've all done it.
Can't just throw that out.
-No.
-No, no, no.
Pro, seeing your face
on the news.
Con, with the headline,
"Olympian suffers frozen penis."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Come on.
The North Pole.
-Um...
[ Laughter ]
Pro, telling your parents
that you're a gold medalist.
Con, having your mom respond
by saying,
"Well, your brother's a lawyer."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Pro, you were able to skate
three miles in six minutes.
Con, now you have to watch
your uber eats driver
take an hour to drive
three blocks.
You're like,
"I -- I can see you.
Just stay there."
[ Applause ]
Pro, training your whole life,
sacrificing so much,
and representing your country.
Con, finding out everyone
was watching "Euphoria" instead.
That's not --
that's a big hit show.
[ Applause ]
And finally, pro, feeling
the thrill of the 360 degree
spin and flips through
the air on your snowboard.
Con, feeling
the same thing on your
flight home
on Spirit Airlines.
There you have it.
Those are the "Pros and Cons."